tá definido os grupos da Libertadores de 2024
e o Flamengo caiu no grupo do Fluminense
e o São Paulo no grupo do Palmeiras.
no grupo a tem o Fluminense que é o atual campeão,
o Flamengo,
o Rasengan e o independente Del Valle,
e no grupo c tem Palmeiras,
Barcelona do Equador,
River Plate e São Paulo.
agora se você entende de Libertadores
você sabe que não teria lógica nenhum esses grupos.
primeiro
dois clubes do mesmo país não pode estar no mesmo grupo,
a não ser que um desses
clubes venha da pré Libertadores,
que não seria o caso de Flamengo e Fluminense
do mesmo grupo
e São Paulo e Palmeiras do mesmo grupo.
se seu coração acelerou,
acelera
que não vai ter São Paulo e Palmeiras mesmo grupo,
nem Flamengo e Fluminense. tá,
o sorteio vai ser da sexta feira.
outra coisa que você não analisou,
o internacional não tá na Libertadores,
quem tá é o Grêmio,
o boca Junior não tá na Libertadores,
o Corinthians não tá na Libertadores,
o Atlético Paranaense não tá na Libertadores.
mas ó, se você realmente
achou que esse seria os grupos da Libertadores,
manda aí pro seu amigo,
manda pro seu amigo palmeirense,
pro seu amigo, pro são paulino,
pro seu amigo que torce pro Fluminense,
pra o seu amigo flamenguista,
porque só de ver Flamengo e Fluminense no mesmo grupo,
São Paulo e Palmeiras no mesmo grupo,
já pensou?
seria cara,
seria bacana
ter esses clássicos dentro do grupo da.
Libertadores,
mas não pode
porque não pode ter dois clubes do mesmo país,
a não ser que venda pra Libertadores.
o sorteio da Libertadores vai ser na sexta feira, tá?
não é esses grupos não.